c'est vous maintenant qu'elle est érigé
les bons points des français normaux
gims il a des convictions ils les
expriment ils pratiquent la religion
musulmane comme il en a envie foutez lui
la paix n'était vous n'êtes pas juste de
vp de la 2 qui émaillent a
séduit
3 mai sur la vie juliette vous êtes
parti gilles excuse moi mais la droite
donnée sociale doit donner son avis
excuse moi qu'est-ce qu'on veut alors
moi tu commences à me gonfler
[Applaudissements]
les importants
et comme ça on est tous les deux
ont fait là bas alors ça me fais quoi
arrête de développement car on redoute
qu'on met en page 6 185
[Rires]
gilles toujours qui font rien et qui ne
font que comme on tété acariâtre et
aigri sait tous comment total
les spéculateurs
données sur lui personne ne veut que tu
prends la place cyril te laisse tomber
plus personne
[Rires]
[Musique]
rediffusion notre corps en sueur
distincts sur terre moi j'ai fait
quelques appels à la démission
diminution mais la mère
était dans toutes les pensées écoute
nombreux tags
[Applaudissements]
les meilleurs
dispositifs d'alarmé c'est vrai on a
mais c'est vrai
mais il avait
toujours du mauvais côté toujours
toujours
nous en aurait repoussé
tu as pas épaté soit aussi
s'il vous plaît je suis rentré julie
donne toujours son avis mexes quittent
l'état contre courant et bailly lomé
mais au moins il a il a le courage de le
faire j'ai désiré avec l'âge j'ai dit
qu'on sait pas pour
être contournées politiquement c'est pas
de nos analyses nos messages ils jouent
pas un rôle il
y dit effectivement tu es tout le temps
à côté de la plaque ou de l'autre côté
ben moi justement je trouve ça bien
parce qu'il a des convictions et il
existe et on n'a pas toujours besoin
d'être du côté de la masse
doit avoir un instinct grégaire
julien des bons français